- What is guten bourbon?
- It's an urban German bourbon.
- Am I just hungover or are
you talking like a Muppet?
- Are you saying the Van Sant camp
wants to recant on Van Camp?
Because they can't!
- There is nothing to least bit funny
about stealing a meal from
Neal McBeal the Navy Seal.
(trumpets)
- I'm determined to get the jargon
of this German bourbon blurbin!
- I used to watch Hank
Hippopopalous' dance pop cosmopolis
every day after school.
I even bought his novelty rap album,
the Hank Hippopopalous Hip Hop Hypothesis.
- I would love to take
take down Hippopolaous
and finally topple the acropolis
of monstrous hypocrisy that ensconces us.
- Caroline, you are my
gritty witty city kitty,
I want you wit' me fitty fitty!
- Slap my salami, they guy's a commie.
- This is turning into a real caper,
a real Jill Pill jail
fail killer whale caper!
- Ooh, a job like that?
You want a fully present
presenter to present,
and I don't know if I've
got the pep in my step
to take that show where
it needs to go, you know?
I've got a real pep-less step, Shep.
- Piper Perabo and Pauley Perrette
need to push back the pitch
on the Princess and the Pauper Project.
- Not if you were the
last albino rhino gyno
on the planet.
- Well, I'm the only
albino rhino gyno I know.
Shall we get some wine?
- Oh great, you're also a wine addict.
You know the actress Courtney Portnoy?
- I think so.
She portrayed the formerly portly consort
in the seaport resort?
- Courtly roles like the
formerly portly consort
are Courtney Portnoy's forte.
But she's got a new action movie
that's supposed to change her image.
Ms Taken, you know Mr Taken
from the Taken movies?
This is his niece!
- Nice!
- This was supposed to be
Courtney's crossover coronation,
but that's sort of bee
thwarted unfortunately,
'cause Courtney's
purportedly falling short
of shoring up four-quadrant support.
- Makes perfect sense so far.
- Portnoy finds joy in hoi-polloi boy toy.
Courtney Portnoy cast in
Corpse Me if you Can-Can,
the 1940s Cannes France-set
story of a can-can dancer
who contracts cancer
but continues to can-can
as a canny cadaver who plays the accordion
with Kevin Corrigan,
Kevin Kline, Chris Klein,
Chris Pine and Chris Kattan.
- Got it.
- McGee, are you still looking for a star
for your transgender Teddy Roosevelt
Planes, Trains and Automobiles reboot,
Plans, Trans, a Man, a Canal, Panama?
Because someone just became available!
- Courtney, more importantly
audiences are going to
adore your tour de force performance
as the forceful denim-clad court reporter
in The Court Reporter Sported Jorts,
the jet-setting jort-sporting
court reporter story!
You know Courtney Portnoy,
you probably recall when she soared
as a thorny hoarder culturist
and and sordid fortnight with
a short-skirted sorceress.
- Uh...
- How would you enjoy joining Portnoy
for a scorched soy porterhouse
pork four-coursers at Koi?
- Wait, what?
- Glorify your sauce,
but don't make it feel forced, of course.
And try the borscht.
- So, a brief recapitulation,
this is not a room for
repudiation or condemnation
over string cheese
appropriation accusations.
Mediation is an invitation
for open conversation.
Frustration, de-escalation
and exchange of information,
which in summation,
removes any justification
for litigation involved
in this corporation.
- I am gross.
I feel, all the time, like a garbage fire,
and not a cozy dumpster in a quaint alley,
but a barge floating out
to sea with no rudder,
I am a rudderless burning
large garbage barge.
- And it suddenly dawned on me.
Hot cock on a rock, she
never even picked up
the little noise and snot factory.
- But that bounce has lost its pounce,
and if we wanna keep
this name in the news,
we're going to need a full court press.
- Tommy schlamme schmommy schlamme.
- Those kids'll be holding
out their hands for Franz,
why grip a Twix when you can Sip-o-wicz?
- Blackery Flack, let's talk frack.
- I gotta live my life!
I deserve to be adored by a man,
yet here my dreams lie dormant.
I don't mean to get mordantly morbid,
but did I get all adorably adorned
to get bored manning doors?
No more!